GROUSING FROM DEMOCRATS.
WE ARE LIVE ON CAPITOL HILL
TONIGHT WITH DETAILS.
GOOD EVENING, MIKE.
>> BRET, DEMOCRATS CLAIMED THEY
WERE SHUT OUT.
THEY WERE ULTIMATELY INCLUDED.
>> AFTER TODAY'S BRIEFINGS LEAD
BY TOP JUSTICE AND MORE, THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSERTED A SPY
IN HIS CAMPAIGN.
>> THERE IS NO EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT ANY ALLEGATION THE FBI
OR ANY INTELLIGENCE AGENCY
PLACED A SPY IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OR OTHERWISE FAILED TO
FOLLOW APPROPRIATE PROCEDURES
AND PROTOCOLS.
>> THE INITIAL PLAN WAS TO MEET,
BUT
INT
IN A BRIEF STATEMENT PAUL RYAN
DEFENDED THE COMMENTS OF LAW
MAKERS.
SAYING HE LOOKED FORWARD TO THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE PROMPTLY
COMPLETING THEIR WORK NOW
THEY'RE GETTING THE COOPERATION
THEY NEED.
ON "FOX AND FRIENDS" PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS ASKED ABOUT AN ATTACK
FROM JAMES COMEY.
HE TWEETED YESTERDAY "FACTS
MATTER" THE TERM IS TIGHTLY
REGULATED AND ESSENTIAL TO
RUNNING THE COUNTRY.
President: THE FIRING OF JAMES
COMEY WILL GO DOWN AS A GOOD
THING.
FBI IS GREAT.
I KNOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE FBI.
IT'S A FANTASTIC INSTITUTION.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE AT THE TOP
WERE ROTTEN APPLES.
JAMES COMEY WAS ONE OF THEM.
I HAVE DONE A GREAT SERVICE TO
THIS COUNTRY GETTING RID OF HIM
AND FIRING HIM.
>> LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYS HE HAS
SERIOUS QUESTIONS OF THE OBAMA
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DURING THE
CAMPAIGN OF 2016.
>> IT'S QUESTIONABLE.
>> THE PRESIDENT MADE REFRPBTS
TO CLAPPER ON TWITTER.
SAYING THERE WAS SPYING IN THE
CAMPAIGN AND LARGE DOLLARS WERE
PAID TO THE SPY, FAR BEYOND
NORMAL ...
>> EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS A
EFFORT TO INCLUDE DEMOCRATS THEY
SUGGEST THE MEET -LGZ SHOULD
HAVE BEEN CANCELED.
>> WHEN ONE PARTY, NUNEZ WANTS
TO DISTORT INFORMATION FOR
PARTISAN PURPOSES, ASKS FOR A
SOLITARY BRIEFING THERE ISN'T BE
A BRIEFING AT ALL.
>> IT APPEARS IT'S A MEETING
THAT COULD BE SHARING
INFORMATION.
THAT SOMEONE'S INTERPRETATION
COULD BE HELPFUL TO THE
PRESIDENT'S DEFENSE.
>> LATE TODAY CLAPPER RESPONDED
TO THE PRESIDENT ACCUSING HIM OF
SPINNING AND DISTORTING WHAT
CLAPPER SAID.
HE SAYS HE TOOK A VERSION OF THE
WORD SPY.